بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد فكلامنا
موصول في تفسير بعض ايات من كتاب الله من
سوره الرعد
منه وقد
وصلنا
الى
الايه الحاد
والعشر والايه
العش ولنواصل
من حيث وقفنا بالامس يقول امس يقول ربنا
سبحانه
وتعالى افمن يعلم ان ما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو اعمى انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب
يعلم يعني يعمل بما
علم العلم
الشرعي المعنى
الشرعي فالمقصود هنا الذي يؤمن ه
هل يؤمن بما انزل اليك من ربك ويعلم انه
الحق ويؤمن بانه الحق هل هو كمان هو اعمى
يعني كمن هو رافض
لذلك كافر بذلك يقول انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب اولو اصحاب
الالباب العقول اصحاب
العقول اصحاب العقول من
هم اصحاب العقول في كتاب الله هم الذين
يوفون بعهد
الله ولا ينقضون الميثاق عهد
الله الذي عاهد الله سبحانه
وتعالى عباده
والعهد الذي بين العباد وبين الله وهو
كتاب
الله وما جاء من امر
ونهي على السنه الرسل هذا هو عهد الله
الموثق وكذلك عهد الله بمعنى العهود التي
اشهد المؤمنون عليها ربهم الله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول يقول الذين يوفون بعهد الله
ولا ينقضون
الميثاق يعني الذي
وثق بين الله وبينهم او
بينهم وبين بعض من المواثيق
العقود يقول تعالى والذين يصلون ما امر
الله به ان يوصل جميع ما امر الله به ان
يوصل
من الاعمال
الصالحه
من
ال
الدفاع
عن
الرسل صله
الرحم يصلون ما امر الله به ان يوصل يقول
تعالى ويخشون
ربهم ويخافون سوء
الحساب جمع الله
تعالى في اولي الالباب الخشي
والخوف و في هذه
العباره
لطيفه مفيده
جدا قد سبق ان ذكرنا ان الخشيه
والخوف في اللغه الخشيه
والخوف
مترادفان في
شيء والخشيه زياده على
الخوف يفترقان في اشياء
الخوف
والخشيه اذا قيل ما الخوف نقول
خشيه ما الخشيه نقول الخوف هذا تفسير
تقريبي لكن ايش الفرق بين الخوف
والخشيه ثم فروق كثيره عدده
العلماء لكن يهمنا
منها امران
او
فرقان الفرق الاول ان
الخشيه تكون
من عظم
المخشي وليس من ضعف
الخاشي يعني الانسان يقول اخشى
كذا فهذا يدل على ان كذا في ال الجمله
هذا المخشي هذا امر
عظيم لان الخشيه لا تكون الا عن عظم
المخشي لان الانسان اذا خاف هذا الخوف
ممكن يكون لان الشيء الذي يخاف
عظيم ممكن يكون بس لان الشخص نفسه ضعيف في
ضعف يخاف وكذا ممكن يكون لانه
ضعيف لكن يخشى كذا فهذا يعني ان هذا الشيء
المخشي هذا شيء
عظيم يستحق
الخوف هذا الفرق
الاول الفرق
الثاني ان
الخشيه لا تكون الا عن
علم لا تكون الا عن
علم ما يمكن
للجاهل ان يقال له يخشى
لا
خشي شيئا اي علم به ف بسبب هذا العلم
وبسبب عظم هذا
الشيء ستحق الخشيه واما
الخوف فالخوف قد يكون عن عن
جهل يخاف كذا ممكن لانه
جاهل او يكون هذا
الشيء جاهل هذه من الامور التي تلم
بالجاهلين لكن اذا خشي فلان شيئا فه هذا
يدل على ان فلان
ماذا عنده علم صاحب علم في هذا
الشيء الله تعالى يقول
ويخشون
ربهم
ويخافون سوء الحساب فجعل الخشيه
لربهم والخوف من سوء
الحساب هذا قد يكون من باب التفنن في
الالفاظ
يعني بدلا من ان ياتي ويخافون ربهم
ويخافون سوء الحساب او ويخشون ربهم ويخشون
سوء
الحساب جاء بهذه العباره وبهذه العباره
تحسينا
للفظ وهذا
ابعد بعيد هذا القول
لماذا لان
القران لا يحتاج الى ذلك بل كل شيء محكم
فيه احكمه الله سبحانه وتعالى من
لذ حكيم خبير
سبحانه
و كذلك مثلا في قوله
تعالى في الفرق بين القلب والصدر ماش
الفرق بعض العلماء يقول نفس الشيء لكن هذا
قول
ضعيف
فهنا قوله تعالى يخشون
ربهم بناء على ما سبق هذا يدل على ماذا
على علم هذا يدل على عظمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وجاء الخوف من سوء
الحساب قد سبق ان ذكرنا ان سوء
الحساب
المحاسبه
بالعدل بدون اي فضل على كل كبيره وصغيره
وهذا سوء بالنسبه
الى الى نتيجه نتيجه هذا الحساب على
صاحبه فان الله تعالى لا يظلم
احدا ولا يظلم مثقال
ذره وكلنا بين فضل الله وعدل
الله فمن جاء يوم
القيامه
وعامله الله بفضله نجى ومن جاء يوم
القيامه وعامل ل الله بعدله هلك
يقينا لذلك يقول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من نوقش الحساب يوم القيامه
عذب عذب ايش مناقشه
الحساب ينظر في كل صغيره
وكبيره هذا لك هذا عليك هذه النظره لك هذه
عليك هذه الكلمه لك هذه عليك هذه النيه لك
هذه عليه ما يمكن للانسان ان ينجو بهذا لا
يمكن لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
قاربوا
وسددوا وابشروا واعلموا انه لن يدخل احدكم
الجنه عم قال ولا انت يا رسول الله قال
ولا انا الا ان يتغمدني الله برحمه من
وفضل الانسان لا يستحق
الجنه والله تعالى يسمي ما يعطي عباده
تفضلا منه اجرا يسميه الاجر صح ولا لا اجر
مثل اجار الاجير تجيب عامل
بتشغله هذا حقه تكل له
اجر لكن هل
يستحقوا الخلق ويفرضون على الله قصرا لا
طبعا ابدا وانما
سمي اجرا لماذا للدلاله على
انه
موفى
اجره لا محاله كحق
ال كحق العامل على
مستاجره هذا هو المقصود نفس الشيء لما
يسمي الله سبحانه وتعالى
الصدقه ويسميه
ايش يقول من ذا الذي يقرض الله قرضا حسنا
يسميه
قرض المقرض متفضل على المقرض اليس
كذلك نقول لا بل الله سبحانه وتعالى غني
عن العالمين بل هو يقول من ذا الذي يقرض
الله قرضا وسماه قرضا لان
الوفاء
به واجب
الوقوع واقع لا
محاله مثل
حق
ال مثل حق المقرض على
المستقرض بس هذه هذه كنايه عباره مبالغه
في في
الكلام
ف هنا جعل الخشيه لله قلنا الخشيه لا تكون
الا عن ماذا الا عن علم والخشيه لا تكون
الا عن عظمه المخشي
صح وجعل الخوف من سوء الحساب قلنا الخوف
قد يكون عن جهل والخوف قد يكون
عن ضعف الخائف صح ولا لا
هذه فائده
عظيمه وذلك ان الانسان اذا علم عظمه عظمه
الله
و علم واعتبر ضعف
نفسه لان الحساب عباره عن عن
المحاسب وال الله سبحانه وتعالى هو
مخشي فلا بد لل للعبد هذا الذي يخشى ربه
ويخاف سوء الحساب عنده ضعف في نفسه وعنده
علم في الله اذا هو يخشى
الله لعظم الله
ويخاف
حسابه سوء الحساب لضعف نفسه والذي يقبل
على الله
بين هذين
الخوفين دائما يخشى الله يخاف
من يخاف من سوء نفسه من
عمله فان
هذا هذا هو النجاه
تماما هذا هو يتولد من بين هذين
الخوفين الحياء من
الله
ومراقبه
و عدم العجب
بالنفس
و ما شابه
ذلك جاء في موطا الامام مالك سنن ابي
داوود من حديث
انس ان
رجلا وقيل شابا من الانصار
مرض فذهب النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لزيارته فلما لقيه
قال كيف انت يا
فلان قال بخير يا رسول
الله
اخشى ارجو الله
واخاف
عملي واخاف
ذنوبي فقال لا يجتمع
هذان في قلب عبد في مثل هذا
الموطن
الا واتاه الله ما يرجو وامنه مما
يخاف وامنه مما
يخاف ف هذا الانسان اجتمع في قلبه ماذا
اجتمع في
قلبه رجاء الله سبحانه وتعالى وهذا لا
يكون الا عن علم
بالله واجتمع في قلبه خوف من
عمله
وهكذا اولو الالباب
ينظرون فيجدون ان الله سبحانه وتعالى عظيم
عظيم يستحق الخشيه كل الخشيه وينظرون الى
اعمالهم يحقرون ويخافون سوء الحساب لانهم
قد الموا بما
لا عذر لهم به بين يدي
الله فيتولد من بين
هذين
من
الحياه والعمل الصالح
وما شابه
ذلك فهذا هو عنوان
السعاده يقول تع
والذين صبروا ابتغاء وجه
ربهم واقاموا الصلاه وانفقوا مما
رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه ويدرؤون بالحسنه
السيئه اولئك لهم عقب
الدار جنات عدن يدخلونها ومن صلح من
ابائهم وازواج
وذرياتهم والملائكه يدخلون عليهم من كل
باب سلام عليكم بما
صبرتم فنعم عقب
الدار نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجعين
‏we the of the 19 20 21 ver 2 سه
الر 13
chapter قران الله سبحانه
وتالى that what has come down upon you
from your lord the truth the one
who is
‏bl the answer obviously is no they are
not the same they not
equal the one who
is blind here this is an analy for the
person who is spiritually
blind the person who
knows knowledge alone is
parad all the people to hell
‏to hell a person can go to the hell
fire unless they
know there are conditions to being
punished and one of those
conditions is that a person have the
intention of disobedience they do
something
knowing that it's incorrect that wrong
that it is that illegal they do this
they know it then they are
‏a person who does not
know this is a type
of
excuse now obviously it's not a blank
excuse but it is an excuse
ness so knowledge alone does
not enter a person into parad
everybody who ends up in pits of hell
knows
‏that came to came to their respec
prophet messenger was the tru
الله
in not
just knowing information or even beli it
knowledge here me by it is
implementation
قران ‏we read the qur when we see
knowledge mentioned knowledge
here it never just means knowledge in
the abstract just knowing something and
has no bearing on a person's life this
is not considered to be knowledge in the
قران when we see the word
knowledge in قران
men it means this inform that a person
has they believe it
‏that
has
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى the one who
knows that what has been sent down upon
you from your lord is the truth the
one who is blind me here the believer
and
disbeliever he says
‏it is
only the individuals of intellect who
will remember rec reflect respond then
he goes into defining these men of
intellect he says these people of
intellect he describes them with a few
descriptions one of these
description they
ff theen
of ‏and they do
not go against
their cen of allah every
indiv has aen الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله some it
لامر
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى has between his
serv
and likewise our
cons those things that we know to be
wrong even if we
can't those
things
‏all الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
bef they fear their lord and further
fear
‏judgement so they keep ties and fulfill
those things that commanded be
fulfilled everything that is to be
fulfilled and ties kept with and like
this is pr as well not only they ties
with
allah
‏ti
is he says they fear their
lord and they further fear po judgement
meaning po judgement on the day of
resurrection that be jed poly by
allah this is not mean jud isan the
outcome of said judgment is for the
recipient that's meant here ‏that a
person will be judged and jg comes in
the form of
absolute unwavering
total
jce that is a very scary
thought we are dealt with by this earth
with with his blessings with his mercy
his forgiveness with his
pardon we conant par with
الله
‏if any point we were to absolute jce
that would be our last day on this
earth because none of
us is compl following the rules none of
uses الله سبحان
وى سحه وتى
‏de us mercy even those who
dis and so on the day of judgment there
is no difference person will be
brought and they will either be judged
by with that pardon or they will be
judged by with that absolute
justice signature unding in the first
place
‏and so a person is judged absolutely
by there is no chance hope for this
person none of us have excuse for
disobedience none of us have an excuse
for
our forgetfulness
for الله سبحانه
وتعالى ‏and so a person is brought forth
on the day of
judgment and given what they are ed
exactly and then what they ow is taken
from them exactly this is a very bad po
judgment
person is in a lot of
trouble and so they fear their lord and
they further fear this judgment ‏do me
الله سبحانه وتعالى
will wrong
them them
deserve rather that's exactly the point
we don't want what we deserve we want
from
allah not based on what we earned but
based on what
allah what is a reflection of allah's
generosity not a refle of our
earnings we are given ‏based on our
ears
we are in a he of trouble however we
want and we ask of allah not because we
deserve but we ask of
allah because he سبحانه وتالى
is because what he gives
generosity is of
his greatest attribut سبحانه وتعالى
والله اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
[Silence]
العالم وعليكم
السلام
[Silence]
‏l